the music is a bop
it is
they really like the jam it's very
different once you get into the game for
some reason
that's like go [ __ ]
mark you know about ghost [ __ ] i was not
we don't pick up or drop anything we
have everything on us that we need
ghosts mark we chase them all right cool
that's it man
well now that i think you guys are all
help
and they never heard from wade again
tyler was tapped to replace wade on the
hugely successful podcast
guys please don't replace me
with you and we will definitely replace
you okay wade you okay
i care and uh i care about you and i
understand your plate
and i'm here for you i don't know that i
trust either one of you can we re brand
our podcast to disrespectable
doctor disrespectable yes never mind
disrespect all right hey dudes i don't
know which one of you is young and which
one of you is on the last legs this is
me what i what can't i do i'm older
okay well
tell us what to do
[Laughter]
man they shouldn't make that icon so big
it's really you want to press it
that's really good wait which button was
that was that middle mouse button it's
the most important oh that's what i
don't want to click it does my camera
die or do i have infinite don't make
hand gestures at me get out of here
that's important you don't want to waste
that all right
[Laughter]
guys are we playing fork knife are we
jailing or are charging up
you almost died because of liquid get
out of here get out of here that's me in
real life in video games i'm great which
is why i play them because i suck so
hard irl yeah yeah whatever i'm gonna go
in there it is baby where's the trailer
okay so uh
i'm sorry is the techno music coming
from the trailer is that what's
happening i think so yes
back in there we were really jamming in
that trailer
also was that one any kind of guidance
so you just want to
go wade what do we normally do hit the
tab i see
tab and see your objectives fire
fire
history got it objective secured
solving the message oh jesus christ
hey um
am i supposed to be like spook oh [ __ ]
am i dead
yes but we can bring you back on the
bottom left you see a little shovel icon
with a five that's the we revive we get
on this difficulty oh okay you have to
go to the cemetery what happened to him
wait no i was in front of the trailer
how did i die so yeah there's like a
circle the moment we started we were
playing the game and i think the ghost
was invisible i saw it on my camera
approaching and watched it grab you and
kill you
so you didn't do anything so you're not
going to help at all you guys wanted
help and i didn't get an answer so i
think i would just let you all [ __ ]
learn sure sure the mean way to go about
it anyway bob don't worry i'll bring you
back
yeah i'm alright how are you gonna go
about that i don't know you said
something about a cemetery so i think i
can figure it out from there okay is
this a cemetery
uh use the compass on the top shut up i
don't want to hear your words i want to
bring bob on my secret mirror bring bob
back to life
hey guys jack northcott was born in 1895
and died oh my god
good god bob you didn't say bob
uh no i'm in a cage
labeled purgatory oh i'm in a cool room
with a ball i'm in a i'm in a bdsm
gazebo
you wow to tell me your name
jack northcutt i don't have a name i
need no name
you don't have a name i don't have a
name i'm okay with that honestly why
would i have a name
are you the one
i'm charles norton
i was 39.
are you dead yeah oh yeah i'm dead oh
that's why you asked if i was down here
oh we each get our own bdsm
you get your own little private slice of
hell um kind of nice mine's nice
actually how do i get when you when you
dig me up how do i get out of here
is it like a birthing situation or i
just got north cut
yeah oh
charles norton all right so how what do
i do if the bad guy comes back wade
that's michael that's when your middle
mouse is useful and the two ways you
know if the bad guy is coming is your
camera if he happens to be invisible you
can see him through your camera or emf
will always tell you if it's getting
close
but emf won't show you what direction
he's coming from so typically you want
to have a partner who
charles norton there it is
who uh one of you wants the camera one
of you emf maybe before you can both go
camera and just watch each other's backs
or you know whatever yeah i see a guy
over here sending this to this grave is
this a bad guy or
hello oh hey what's up dude hey what's
up i got the emf out
there you go do i get a press button
well no thanks to wade what are we doing
now all right i think we need to uh go
to the baldwin house
uh
i have a couple markers on my compass
that don't mean anything to me cemetery
borley house yeah
baldwin house appears to be northwest of
us i have no reason to believe we need
to go to the baldwin house it just felt
right well there's an executive that
says that we should solve the mystery of
the mirror in the baldwin house oh well
that was a good guess then i didn't know
about that
you're not appearing on my camera wait i
think mark is a vampire oh
it says now i am stuck in purgatory
telling others which grave you're in oh
did you glitch out no i'm here okay all
right let's go shall we house
all right
um another thing worth noting
just throwing this out there
there is broken glass
right in front of me right now and there
are cans right here king said things
yeah stepping in that or hitting cans
will uh more likely it's more likely to
draw the thing to come i stepped to the
side of it
great i call shenanigans no monster thus
far i got my emf out i'm listening wow
hello yeah are you seeing the lady you
see in this lady oh baby how are you
doing
he's not in here i'm taking getting a
big fat nothing on the emf over here
just so you guys know
well we're probably pretty safe then oh
yeah so if there's like a guy behind
mark is that bad
yes i'm not getting any emf do i got to
press a button no no no if you have it
out it's just working what was that
oh glass
later this is one of two alternatives
this is where i got killed
oh great well you got killed near the
altar cool that seems cool
i just stepped in glass that's bad
that's fine hey look there's glass right
here
whoa whoa
hey guys i found him
well
we both just flashed so now we don't
have any charges left to save ourselves
i found him guys
oh [ __ ] he's right back uh uh what do we
do what do we do
i'm getting a big reading i'm getting a
reading i'm getting a big reading i'm
getting a big read there's a big reading
there
does he just leave after that or
oh wow
back to the cemetery i'm all right i'm
now charles dudley i'm a different human
okay this is a training exercise
everyone
it's a training exercise you know you're
acting all self-righteous like you're
telling us wade but you're really not
explaining very much you guys want me to
tell you stuff and you both didn't say
yes but then you're acting all
belligerent like you are explaining
things and we're idiots for not
understanding what's happening you guys
aren't stupid for nothing uh-huh you're
stupid asking questions
uh-huh
so it's only gonna be the crips in here
you don't worry about the little smaller
tombstones
so just look at the the big look at that
mirror makes me nauseous charles dudley
born 1860 hannah dudley no charles
dudley 1860 1860-1882
perfect
ripe old age of 22.
that's bad yeah that's not too good
the dude's here and i'm gonna die nope
he's going for you oh he's going for
mark
this guy is very violent
he's [ __ ] standing in the thing he
just came out over the guy like i got
him
they call that spawn camping on that's
not fair that was a little dirty though
mark is going to be john holton no i'm
charles colby
well dick 1878.
charles jack northcott
i don't like this john camden oh this
one's creepy all right now the guy's
gonna come back and kill you all right
after you spawn i love that
ready
i think um we did kick bottles one of us
did on the way here i don't know if it
was me or bob i wasn't thinking about it
what the hell kind of why is there just
bones everywhere this is a bad cheaply
run graveyard yeah it really is lazy
that is a good point literally just pile
of bodies with a tombstone next to it
what does the crystal do uh okay so your
camera again helps you identify the
ghost memories invisible
uh emf shows you where the ghost is in
general the third thing number three is
a word you place on the ground
uh however i think it was already used
there is a way to rechargeably go to the
orphanage for that but that puts a ward
on the ground that will capture the dude
he can still grab you if you run at him
while he's in there but it'll hold him
in place and like banish him away
eventually for a short time okay guys i
see him
there's two easier two or three harder
difficulties i kind of ran away from
that one i feel like that was perfectly
run away we might be able to
um you guys can keep going if you want
to if you don't oh son of a [ __ ] no no
we're coming
we either all win or we all lose
i think it was in the back row charles
dudley
i'm making a lot of noise what happens
if you interact with a bad one
it makes a lot of noise i'm interactive
oh someone sees me someone how do you
know someone sees you i heard a big
voice that was like oh
yeah okay that's a pretty plain message
i guess yeah i keep hearing noise that's
not good um it's okay margaret is this
marcus like kicking a bottle around in
front of him i'm looking up not down my
eyes through the sky not the ground
i will say some glass piles i don't know
about bottles or cans but i know some
glass piles are actually invisible for
some reason you only see those through
your camera i'm getting ems
[Music]
oh it's gone
okay that's good
so uh watch the cans here kansas bottles
all right uh number four is like a ward
[Music]
all right okay well let's just end this
then
[Laughter]
by winning
hey i made it to 61 this time we might
want to stop here bob no you guys go you
got this
no i mean we might want to stop oh [ __ ]
he's back come inside come inside follow
me put the thingy on the door that will
keep us safe
i'm over here you piece of [ __ ] oh you
kind of peek through it though don't you
yeah he will try to be grabby hey what's
up dude it seems like there's what's up
you dumb [ __ ] oh see ya
uh so what are we doing that's number
four four is the door award five the
crystal can reveal secret things so we
will do that five here does that door
ward go away yes
it wears off good good
yeah how long does that last
um i'm surprised it's still there after
actually working on him it's gone now
okay i'm gonna just do another one of
them real quick
[Music]
hey guys good job you did it yeah we're
winning mark we're doing this for you
one tenth of the way there
wow i'm proud of you guys i hear more
cans being kicked i love that for us
that wasn't me it was not me this time
like the ghost of marcus kicking cans
something makes me believe that you're
telling the truth i don't know why i
don't know why either wait wait can i
get an enough reading
uh
on and off it's fine all right i'm gonna
trust that and i'm gonna jump off here
and just believe that there's nothing
near but it will hurt me
sure
sure sure okay uh okay you go to the old
church there's two churches old church
and regular church when you go to the
old church
orphanage and baldwin house oh bob bob
to the right he's coming right towards
oh hey what's up dude the middle mouse
button when he gets close
there you go what's up a-hole
oh he's so sad
all right all right so we don't cross
the bridge so how did you get more of
the middle mouse finding the boy by
completing
[Music]
i think on easy and very easy it
recharges on its own but on normal and
above you have to get it from getting
the pieces of the toy
okay there's some cans over here
hey i got an achievement hey wait i'm
getting an emf reading
oh jesus christ
i don't know if he came from behind me
or what but he got me man he got me all
right good luck
you got this you guys have left with all
the tools i need for victory we clearly
have all the charges and things there
was some out behind that door did you
see all the mystery of the baldwin house
with the camera unfortunately these
tasks there's only so many of them there
are a variety of them but there's only
so many so i know that there's a
solution to this one mystery of the
mirror with the camera you take a
picture of the mirror and it shows you
where the toy's going to be her squirt
who was that walking around oh guys
just somebody that i used to know
[Music]
i've got a charge wow what's this about
a toy
the bottom left there's like a little
toy image and uh we're slowly getting
the pieces to put that toy together and
then once we have the pieces we have to
sacrifice the toy at these altars
go into the orphanage so bob what's your
purgatory like it is a room filled with
coffins and statues with
uh sheets over them it's very spooky
i have the cage room like a marion
kimberly crump to july
down the
markers
i'm trying to read these things but
they're they're very scribbly whoever
wrote all these words on this coffin did
a bad job blimp
blimp
blimp
and mal
round randolph
are you what's happening all right
trying to read man i'm trying to read
these coffins i'm trying to learn i
don't have anything to read in mine
except my name plate and i've read it so
many times can i get on top of this
coffin maybe this one's easier to read
no it's the same scribbles man they
really should have proof proofread this
before they put on all these coffins
whoa
somebody really freaked up what was the
laughing all about
can i pray i can pray oh hey wait what
you
looking at i don't know if you saw that
i got slightly jump scared yeah there
was like a lady leaning down from the
attic or something yeah that was new
you gotta win
we completed the quest guys we did it
guys we did it
we did
it i'm trying to pray but it ain't
working what's 140 fov look like oh
it's too high
why god oh why oh no this is not what
you wanted it's a real gaming experience
here
oh
man
holy [ __ ] i can see everything a 30 30
field of view
i have the vision of an iguana oh my god
i see an n
okay well i have to see about that oh
man
what am i sniping i think so
this might help me read the coffins oh i
can i can look through wade's eyes
better than he can oh i'm looking i'm
looking at your screen your camera is
bigger than my field of view like the
screen on your camera
so i kind of cheated on that one and i'm
supposed to go solve a mystery but i
just guess it's only three things so i
just kind of like oh disgrace to you
yeah you know i think wait if you're a
true friend you join us in death i
thought about it
and then i realized i don't like doc
long enough yeah not long enough come on
come on man come on i mean the ghost
that even showed itself am i supposed to
do just join us
die to what join us oh kick somebody
that changed some glass that scarecrow
changed for a second did you see it
oh
it seems i've stumbled into some glass
oh some crazy stuff's happening what's
up see you're still fighting you're
still doing what is this about no i can
count
what is this about
here you are
oh hey buddy is he stuck is this he's
really bad he's really ignoring you
don't ignore me come back i think this
was good
i think this is literally rigged yeah it
is
wade just bumped into the ghost and he
was all oh i gotta go
literally trying to summon this thing to
come murder you're not clearly not or
else you'd be dead
stomping i wasn't even trying to die and
i died soon just stopped being stuck
here oh hey sorry here we
can we fly now whoa
oh no
we diddy kong racing into the grave
i missed that all right well now you
guys know how to play and you're
professionals right
huh
time played four minutes yeah i guess i
was out for about four minutes
that was pretty much
[Music]
you